[Music]
off of bark bark how dare you welcome
back to bark bark bark bark why are you
looking outside
rofl welcome back to the Julian podcast
I'm a dog that all started because the
pub gee this episode is brought to you
by dogs everywhere Wow
your dog my dog his dog her dog this
episode is brought to you by me undies
which by the way shouts out me and he's
reposted the picture I posted of my butt
in my me undies and now I can forever
send it to Rome to piss her off because
she hated it Mandy's guys the best
underwear out there delivered right to
your door new designs each month and a
special member pricing meaning if you
sign up to be a member with me undies
you get better deals on their underwear
and they also have socks and bra that's
right now go to meet undies that's ME
und IES comm / Tirana Julian give 15% of
your first pair and free shipping also a
100% satisfaction guarantee check it out
also guys equip the toothbrush that you
didn't know that you needed it is a
compact ultra slim ultra convenient
electric toothbrush backed by a network
of over 10,000 dental professionals it
looks like it was designed by Apple is
super clean and it has guided pulses to
give you the best brush that you can
possibly get also they send you refills
of bristle tips on a regular schedule so
you are always getting the best brush
you can get starts just $25 right now
and when you go to get quit that's GE
tqu IP comm slash annejulien you get
your first refill pack for free check it
out and start brushing y'all Thank You
sponsors Thank You sponsors by the way
that picture that we took in Pittsburgh
joints in the hotel room in his
underwear he goes will you take a
picture of me I'm like sure you are you
like you just gonna be in yeah he's like
yeah and he turns around you do this but
out took that picture I didn't think you
were gonna post it I don't even know
what you're really getting at he gets so
like Aries here just
take a picture of my butt and then he
wouldn't stop air-dropping it to Rome
what like you've never posted a picture
of your butt I'm not allowed to post
picture my butt you can do whatever you
want boy don't come in there what
happened I didn't know what was
happening what happened was B it just
worked out I was feeling nice I was
feeling myself we get back to the room
Jenna goes dan your butt looks good I
take a picture it's not what happened at
all
what happened right fine I asked her to
take a page for my butt so I I took the
picture my butt and immediately after
looking at it I was like these are
probably my favorite pair of manatees
it's the one with the roses on them so
you know I was like you know I'm gonna
post it and and give a little love to me
and ease and I did and Rome replied to
my DM saying what did she say I'd like
that it makes me so uncomfortable it
makes me so uncomfortable so then I
started air-dropping the picture to her
all trip because well that's what you do
right also weirdly that was the picture
because I tagged where we were Pittsburg
that was know that was the picture that
Dylan saw and we found out that we were
both in the same city because of so me
and he's brought us and our friend Dylan
together in a city that neither of us
are from or had any idea the other
person was in like that was crazy but
yeah anyway Mandy's great thank you me
and you and if you get me any zeal make
new friends and that clean but that is
not backed by the FDA but anyway we just
got back from Pittsburg Jenna did an
appearance at Slippery Rock University
how was that it was so fun they were so
hype like I I it's so bizarre right cuz
we just like live and work here alone in
the house all the time
so then when you just like occasionally
because it's not like frequent enough
for you to ever get used to it right you
just like you walk out into a room of
all these people and they're like super
[ __ ] excited and you're like this
feels so weird like wow thank you for
this warm welcome I don't know why I'm
here or what y'all want me to do except
talk about life I don't know I was
expecting
of like energy but I wasn't expecting it
to be that crazy yeah well because a
small university yeah yeah yeah you pull
you've done so many of them by now every
school every school is different some of
them are like super academic and they
have questions or more loads yeah
Edmonton was all they wanted to talk
about was like mental health and like
taking care of yourselves it's like
beautiful and wonderful but you know
different the University of Arizona was
like the most hype crowd I've ever
[ __ ] I would argue that slippery rock
was more hype honestly well the Arizona
one that we did was like one of the
first ones and people were just it was
just like shouting out from the crowd
non-stop like it definitely far get a
Harry Potter shot I'm like what's a
Harry Potter job like they light it on
fire the whole crowd goes [ __ ] nuts
like I don't know what's happening
because you you they definitely felt
like a big University like a big party
Chris slippery rock was like that the
rock was hype as far call me wild it was
wide it was like they were they
basically they have this gym right where
the basketball court of all you walk or
than they have like the upstairs track
that looks down on it and they like
opened up the door so it's like they
extend to the gym put 1,500 frickin
foldable chairs on the gym floor and
when they were screaming it was like
deafening it was like so loud like it
was so tight like shouts out to a person
named Joey who showed up dressed up as a
chair like he had my face paint on to be
a chair and I just looked out in the
crowd and I just see this chair staring
back at me it's probably one of my
favorite moments of my life that was a
really really good the one row you know
was intense it was a lot of [ __ ]
people but it went really well right so
like that's a funny point that you said
that I kind of wanted to talk about for
a sec like we're in her house
99% of the time yeah and our work
filming the podcast filming videos
streaming on Twitch and in which all of
these scenarios involve no human
standing there watching yeah it's just
that we're clapping work I mean you know
live feedback and then you go into a
room like that yeah like that's I mean I
was there with you so I know what it's
like but can you like put into words
what that switch is like you know these
people know every little
thing but you never see them oh yeah I
mean for most people that do that kind
of stuff it's like you're on tour or
something where you like you get used to
being on stage yeah like I don't do any
sort of like live performances really so
it's just like occasionally a few times
a year you're just in a room with a ton
of people and they're like be good at
public speaking and you're I'm literally
alone all the time this is a lot but
like that crowd when I when I walked out
there like just like the energy and like
the love that you get from people I
thought like it makes you want to cry
like I instantly felt like I wanted to
cry you know what I mean if I wasn't
trying to like keep it together and like
make it up the stairs without falling
down like that's the kind of thing that
like I would just saw that I mean it's
intense but yeah it is it all it all is
very positive for you like that's a
specific thing for when you do these
things that's why and it's so funny
because you'll be like hell yeah and
then they just use their [ __ ] minds
oh my god crazy dude
all right because it's much different
than like reading a Twitter mansion or
like reading twitch chatter yeah reading
YouTube now it's just like so visceral
in there true it also just like it blows
my mind like first of all that schools
are open to having like non-traditional
people they're you know like this Josh
Peck was there though he's an actor you
know like no but he's also internet now
exactly but like the fact that schools
invite me I'm like that's that's pretty
cool you know and progressive of them to
not be boxed in to like having some type
of academic speaker there or someone I
don't know it just seems rad yeah if it
blows my mind a little bit but I also
realized that my school had nobody
[ __ ] cool ever come you didn't have
nobody
you're sure you just might not
absolutely sure we did it wasn't a thing
we I went to one like my freshman year
and she was like an author but as really
small one yeah yeah but like that was a
no like celebrity is nothing like that
no when we didn't have like musical
events with like you know you go to
these schools that have like these big
like festivals for their students
essentially with like you know a couple
people like playing nearly it's so cool
like well in the New England area they
were like massive schools that would
have like these big things put on by
they're big budgets and their music
government yeah and they have like like
really cool people commonly yeah we get
[ __ ] anybody yeah we had well so
Chapman I think in my like last two
years of Chapman there were more of like
the music events where they had like DJs
or whoever come and like fill the gym
and I never I think I myself when I was
once and I hated it because it's like
wasn't my scene but but the only speaker
I can remember and I went to it was rain
Wilson which was really that's really
cool ya know that was really rad but I
mean I agree with you like I agree that
it's it's cool that they're inviting
Internet people
now as yeah as the rain Wilson's like as
the celebrities to the school because
like sometimes and appearances they'll
allow one of the student government
representatives a student basically
interview you or moderate and I love
when they do that because it feels like
just like your peers almost right like
you're talking to someone who
understands everything and this recent
one there was a faculty member doing the
interviewing and I was fine and she was
great but at the same time you could see
on her face when you would say something
and people would lose it that she was
like is crazy like I did my research but
I couldn't prepare what the hell is
going on yeah so yeah I just think it's
really cool that like the schools that
have budget for that kind of thing as
clearly mine didn't or like just I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened we didn't
get anything cool but you know they give
these students a budget and it's the
student government's that reach out to
like book people that they want to see
or that they think that the student body
would want to sees I think that's cool
but the school's give the students the
liberty of picking their own guests and
doing that kind of thing
yeah and that's sort of like will answer
the questions that would normally flood
the comments like this like come to my
school well that's how it happens right
started yeah basically like my youtube
friends be like how did you get started
doing that I'm like it was just like one
student government yeah that was like we
want a book use like yeah I don't have a
live show but like we could do a QA you
can make it whatever you want like you
can have a student do it we can do like
open questions and answers
like it's your time it's your school
like whatever your school wants me to do
like let's just do it let's have fun
yeah and then it was like contagious
because then people were like well now
my school wants you to come which is the
coolest way to do it because it took one
I guess forward-thinking student
government I think you of a was the
first one right I think so to put that
out Vince there's an offer a fee and fly
you out like the whole thing and then
you do it once and it looks legit and it
is legit and so all these other schools
I can't even count on it's hard to think
about all the ones we've done that's a
lot like I there's so many of them yeah
done you've been doing it for like four
years I don't even know yeah but like if
you're in a student government and I
don't know how that stuff works since
I've never been in a college like
student government like if there's a
youtuber or a person or something that
you think your school would like like if
it's [ __ ] Shane Dawson or like
Batman's outrageously busy at this point
but like there's no harm in just like
reaching out and cuz that's how it
happened to me you know like even asking
questions like what would it take how
does this work right you know we'd love
to formally invite you can you give us
some information of what it was yeah
what happens you know what I mean but
it's not like you know hey my name is
Jessica and I'm reaching out to you and
I really like you and want you to come
it was like they they gave us know yeah
they did the right way which is though
anyway that was our weekend it was like
a pretty quick turnaround fly-in fly-out
but you did awesome it was really cool
to see you in person it's just wild
it's wild to like be alone all the time
and then all of a sudden you're just
like on a stage right oh [ __ ] what the
hell is going on
in Slippery Rock was like a really
beautiful school we got to see like a
little bit of the facilities it's really
nice yeah well I had friends that went
to Slippery Rock yeah like there's a lot
of you know people in upstate New York
that go to SUNY schools or then they go
to like parts of New England or they go
to Pennsylvania's a lot of schools of
Pennsylvania yeah and it's not far so
it's like four hours from where I grew
up so you could just drive home mm-hmm
closer than Boston like I drove six
hours you know that kind of blew my mind
when you were like we're closer to
Rochester than that and then we would be
in Boston I like didn't realize that
yeah anyway don't even get me started
on how excited I am to play don't even
get me started part a this is like a we
did a long time ago yeah this is you
always ask us to keep doing it but we
you have to like wait and enough time
till they come up with things that you
could even say so this game for those
who don't know is a ranting game where
we compile the list of things that we
could rant about and we're each going to
pull we're gonna take turns pulling
these things from the cup and then we're
gonna start our rant by saying don't
even get me started about this sudden
you have to argue whatever's in there
even if you don't fully believe it yeah
after you because there's a couple that
general I came up with in this couple
that I came up with so like she might
get mine and make it ours so we're just
gonna like rant a little bit for you and
there you go so enjoy that ranting un go
first
I see that you didn't fold any of these
so I can see where I would a baby it's
not it's not Virgo season anymore
sleeper season all right I have don't oh
oh oh don't even get me started on why
soup is the perfect food so glad I
didn't get that one it is so perfect it
is perfect in any weather I don't care
if it's hot out it's a perfect meal it's
like because there's enough liquid in
there it's like satiating and hot even
if it's cold if you're eating like a
gazpacho it's like just the perfect meal
like there's a reason why when you're
sick you want some soup because it's
nourishing delicious salty I swear on my
life that if you're hungover
the best hangover meal is soup because
it's not solid enough to like make you
feel sick and queasy but there's enough
sodium in there to get you back on your
feet and make you feel good you know
what I'm saying it's portable you could
put it in a thermos boiling what the
hell you could drink it or you can eat
it for someone that likes orange juice
with pulp and we've had this
conversation as nauseum about how it's
kind of gross a little bit to drink
something with solid chunks and it soup
is that but it is a food and it's
delicious you should agree with me and
people who have like jaw or teeth
problems or injuries can still eat soup
old people can eat it babies can eat it
people of all ages can eat it it's
perfect food it any kind of food that
you like can be made into a soup and it
is
delicious tortilla soup [ __ ] who
invented that chili is fantastic
although I don't think that's a soup
that's more of like a stew but honestly
stew I'm here for them as well
I grew up on beef stew it is [ __ ]
amazing you put it in a pot you simmer
it it's easy to cook it's cheap to cook
you can throw anything in it and it's
delicious I shouldn't have gotten you
started don't even get me started I
don't like when people would make fun of
me in the middle of summer when I would
order a soup because [ __ ] you
this is delicious and I'm gonna [ __ ]
eat it okay do you agree with I now
agree with you do you agree well I don't
think soup is the perfect but I mean
what's the perfect food probably pizza
or pad thai probably today pad thai soup
can you put pad thai in soup yeah some
rice noodles and some soup okay you sold
me a few it'll be like a salmon with
like different noodles is robbing the
soup I don't know ramen is a soup so is
five Baz definitely well if it's been
ramen yeah then yeah there soon all
right so that you use that argument and
then you win me over if ramen is in the
category I'm Holly ramen I think ramen
might be a soup ramen is a suit ramen
might be a soup what in what scenario is
it not a soup well I mean I feel like
this is a debate like you could debate
this if it's a noodle dish but the the
basis of what makes it special is the
broth then it should be considered as
well cuz if you take away the liquid
from ramen it's not ramen a but there's
still ramen noodles yeah that's part of
the soup thank you ramen noodles is
different than ramen yeah what makes
ramen ramen is the broth mm-hmm which
are the soup tell you away the broth is
just ramen noodles mmm but I want ramen
so that's the soup mm-hmm I think so
right good job good first rant you you
didn't even offer me anything one I
think you just kind of like I'm not
supposed to like vehemently opposed I'm
just trying to like maybe poke a hole or
two and let you in
it's the perfect fit well how is PK why
is it better than Pizza how about that
how can you have cheesy soup
I want cheesy soup what are you talking
about cheesy soup is good because of the
onion soup are like stuff with cheese in
it I've never had that in my life they
make like bacon cheeseburger soup no
they don't
yes they do okay nothing you can make
anything with cheese in it with soup
like you just throw cheese in it you
want chicken noodle on cheese soup yeah
minestrone soup with like a little gloop
of cheese and they're so amazing gloop
gloop what about tomato soup with
grilled cheese I don't understand why
people need to have tomato soup when
they have grilled cheese you already
have I'm gonna get [ __ ] on for this
because I know how many people love to
me I said but they're grilled cheese but
for me I'm just gonna double up on
grilled cheese if you're gonna get a
side order get me a grilled cheese with
a side order grilled cheese I don't need
a side of soup to go away that I want
more of the grilled cheese I don't need
to dip it in anything it tastes and it
balances out alright I don't believe in
that why do you think people make
grilled or a grilled cheese sandwich
with tomato slices on it don't believe
anything balances are now even balancing
acidity or anything in food I like to
put tons of lime on everything vicinity
no no like no way like you hate when I
cook and I don't have like sugar to
something because you're like it needs
balance and I'm like no just more lime
more salt it's so gross don't do that I
hate that no no I'm not I'm not the
business of balancing food I'm just not
will be making like a dressing in the
blender and I'm like oh like taste this
how do you think it tastes on lemon what
it could use some lemon Emily who's
literally no lemon in this in this
dressing like Caesar salad Caesar
dressing like she doesn't like putting
lemon in and I'm like tongue if you
taste things the way that Julian likes
them it like literally hurts your tongue
he's like slash your tongue on the ass
and your tongues like oh all right
that's what happens when you put lemon
is the person
food okay it fills you up you know what
I don't fully agree but I've never slept
that statement from you I don't think I
can ever fully agree with that statement
sorry well you're wrong okay eight out
of ten dead wrong oh don't even get me
started on how many times I ran the mile
growing up for no reason all of those
cold mornings at PE when I had a period
and we had to jump on that stupid track
and run the mile just so some
out-of-shape PE instructor cuz there
with his stopwatch and judge your mile
time over and over and you worked hard
you were basically an Olympic athlete I
ran a sick I were in a sub six-minute
mile in elementary school my best was
six and I really got 545 in like fifth
grade yeah and I was a dude I was
busting ass I was I was training I was
thinking about it before school I was
thinking about it after school I
couldn't I could not stop thinking about
how important this stupid mile was and
then what it's like cursive writing it
doesn't even [ __ ] apply in real life
am I gonna be a track star 1% chance
there was one guy who I liked competed
with in elementary school to be a better
mile runner and he [ __ ] wolf to my
ass and he ended up being a track like
guy in high school and that's great but
for the rest of us imagine all of this
[ __ ] we could have been getting done
instead of running around that stupid
cold dirty track in the morning I mean
you're not wrong it seems like okay one
lap get warmed up you don't need to run
a freaking mile you don't need to have
it be part of your test you don't need
to be worried about times you don't need
to be gassing yourself out you don't
need to be sweaty for the rest of the
day it's not like you had a locker room
in elementary school you were just
sweaty I feel like you could do it like
once a year as like a measurement like a
physical fitness test right like you do
it once but like you don't need to do it
more than once I do think that there is
some validity in that it can measure
your level of physical fitness what so
many times I can't even tell you we were
in it so many times it sounds like you
just had a really lazy gym teacher that
was like I had a lot of lazy gym
teachers really yeah so like in middle
school right six
seventh-grade worship eighth-grade you
got to play football basketball soccer
you got to play the real sports six and
seventh grade was like hacky sack dance
class juggling squared is really dumb
[ __ ] understand Vegas unit it was the
weirdest curriculum like disparity
between 6th 7th and 8th grade but one
thing that remained is all three grades
had to run the [ __ ] mile over and
over and over
oh you're doing juggling course for
three months okay we'll run the mile so
you can get better at throwing balls in
the air and catching them oh my god why
is the mile so important why not a
kilometer why not
why a mile why not like a hundred meter
dash yeah like I would have been such a
better athlete I would have been drafted
out of high school if we practice the
hundred meter dash and not the mile why
would I ever need a mile run a mile
except the sport where you're literally
running for sport not everyone wants to
be a track star
hundred meter dash all day dude all day
I don't need endurance no no you can if
you're gonna go to soccer practice and
get endurance but like for PE run the
[ __ ] hundred meter dash okay I could
have had such a better 60 meter dash
time and I would have been scouted and
drafted immediately if I had been
practicing that but what's the gym
teacher gonna do to kill like 10 minutes
20 minutes while they wait for that one
little [ __ ] kid to be like I'm not
doing this I'm gonna walk the mile so
many people who were that kid in middle
school and I I was never the kid but I
identify with the people who did that
we're like I'm not doing it and I'm not
changing for gym here's a note from my
doctor
or my mom who says I'm unfit to run the
mile today so eat it PE teacher I
identify with that person I was never
that person but I get it yeah so much
okay the amount of people who did that
would have been chopped in half if it
was 100-meter dash not the mouth cuz all
you gotta run is one stretch of the
track and you're done but like I feel
like your gym your gym teacher was
trying to kill time or like they had
nothing to do that day so they're like
all right kids we're running a mile do a
hundred percent this is the whole period
by the time you walk to the track you
get everybody outside get them to all
stretch and especially the kids who
walked
[ __ ] yeah 15 minutes 20 minutes and
they're like okay that's my mom cuz you
finished yours in six minutes so then
you sit there on the track for 15
minutes unless you're Jim that's another
thing because they're waiting I worked
my ass off I was trying to do my best at
the marks I'm like this matters we're
doing this I have to do well in it I run
it in six minutes and then I'm like
huffing and puffing breathe and chilling
and then all these people are walking
their way past the finish line and I'm
like okay if that person got an A and I
got an a what the [ __ ] did I just spend
my energy on it I don't disagree with
you that we it does seem a little
unbalanced that you have kids run a mile
but you don't have them work on their
Sprint's at all you know you do do that
we did the shuttle thing where you just
you drop the little shuttles the baton
thing no shuttles what's the shuttles
you just run back and forth because
there's suicides
suicides yeah but we call them shuttles
those are gnarly those at least make you
a better athlete sure I don't think that
makes you a better athlete
unless you're your sport is no
long-distance running
sorry that was like the main source of
my anxiety growing up is the mile I was
fine with the mile I feel like we didn't
I was it as much as I wasn't fine with
it cuz I needed to be good at it and so
it caused anxiety because I was like I
have to do well the miles tomorrow it's
okay don't even get me started get me
started don't even get me started
oh why does Pittsburgh put french fries
[ __ ] salads this is something we
didn't know until we went to Pittsburgh
this past weekend Dillon told us about
it he ordered a salad and it came with
french fries and all the salads come
with french fries it's pretty salad in
the salad with like ranch and cheese
that's not a salad the fries with
lettuce it's cheese and
and lettuce right yeah if you say I'll
have a Pittsburg salad hold the lettuce
you just got cheese fries you just got
poutine with ranch weird poutine weird
poutine yeah that's not a salad yeah if
it if it is you can't call it a
Pittsburgh salad you have to call it a
french fries salad well because people
from outside of Pittsburgh think that
you're just getting like some local
delicacy a local salad oh maybe there's
an apple or something I don't know it's
french fries it's something I wasn't
aware of I also didn't know that people
put french fries in a salad mm-hmm mm-hm
and then have the gall to call it a
salad who absolutely you [ __ ] full
and a salad for lunch oh yeah what was
in your salad french fries ranch cheese
that's not a salad you can't call it
that hmm also maybe since we're on that
topic and we were on the topic of soup
and what makes a super soup what makes a
salad a salad I think the primary
ingredient is of leaf well what about
potato salad or macaroni salad then
you're just subbing the leaf out with
another word it's like potato salad
instead of actual salad so I think I
don't I think salad as a classification
of food doesn't really encompass like
the potato or the mac salads because
like those are those are live turn a
diversion no those those are lies that
people made up their lives their lives
with carbs is what they are and the
Pittsburg salad is even in a bigger lie
because it doesn't have a precursor to
the the word salad it's just a Pittsburg
salad and it's not a salad it's got
[ __ ] potatoes it is a lie because at
least if you're making macaroni salad
you're like I know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing I'm eating pasta yeah because the
dish is macaroni right a Pittsburgh
salad is like I'm having this salad for
lunch
salad is whatever you throw in it jeez
it's like when they made pita pizza
vegetable remember that know who made
pizza you remember when they classified
pizza is a vegetable for like month I
don't know no no I don't know it was
like some thing I don't actually know
that
is not bread no they did it was a
vegetable for a hot minute okay but if
pizzas a vegetable then the Pittsburgh
salad is a real salad mmm which neither
of them [ __ ] are I don't disagree
with you that I feel like a salad should
be defined as like some type of
vegetable is the base mm-hmm but but
anything beyond that y'all would lie in
it when it's a saddle so like we gave
you were the salad board okay we're like
a little salad we're defining what
salads are okay we gave you croutons you
can have pieces of carb bread in in your
mix of lettuce and that'll be part of it
will allow that much because we want a
popularize this thing mm-hmm and you're
gonna throw that in our face and put
french fries on it no absolutely not and
cheese you can't just do that
note about a salad in a bread ball is
that a licen those are things the salad
in the bread roll is only soup in a
bread bowl a salad in a bread bowl with
fries on it oh my god
what about there's no order anymore what
about a pizza with a salad on top of it
is that a pizza or a salads a pizza
salad a salad pizza it's stupid is what
it is it's a waste of time and
ingredients and money probably get a
fresh vegetable pizza or don't get a
pizza get a salad the kids just do both
I feel like a salad should be considered
something that's like you know lettuce
as the base or something you know that's
it the recipe the rest of what y'all be
calling salads like pasta salad or mac
salad or potato yeah if there's another
food group in flew all just made a dish
you made it finish with the word salad
and you can borrow the word salad but
it's not a salad but I think what
they're trying to define as a salad by
calling something like a potato salad a
salad is that you chop something and
threw it into a bowl with a dressing yes
yeah yeah and that's fine that's it like
I said that's the second classification
no that's a dish no no that's it's it's
like a it's a it's a urging of a salad
sort of salad I don't think yeah I don't
think just because you chopped something
and put it in a bowl with a dressing on
it doesn't make it ass out no but it's a
type of like it's an alternate version
of no I think it's a lie okay all I'm
saying is just because you said
Pittsburgh before the word salad don't
make it a [ __ ] salad I agree I feel
like Pittsburgh as a whole needs to be
more descriptive about what's in it for
salad not just right Pittsburgh salad so
when you get it there's just loaded with
fries all right Newton don't even get me
started on how expensive the traditional
electric toothbrush is do don't even get
me started
you should get flip that is way more
affordable and the better toothbrush for
you and your brushing habits right now
guys if you go to get quip
that's GE t qu IV document slash jenna
julie quip starts at just $25 and with
that URL you get your first refill pack
for free what is a refill pack you ask
well it's a new brand new bristle head
for your toothbrush that gets replaced
on a regular schedule so you're not
using and wearing down the same bristles
over and over for months and months and
months no they were sending you new ones
and the first pack of refill bristles
for you will be on the house because you
use our URL and you are a wonderful
person right now guys what is quip well
it's a newer more modern more affordable
and just as functional electric
toothbrush that is super sleek super
clean looking travel friendly and great
for your teeth it has guided pulses to
help you get the best brush it is backed
by thousands of dental professionals and
it doesn't come with a high price tag
which is the best part don't even get me
started on how good quip is they say you
refill past well it is super low profile
it looks great on your on your your your
bathroom counter or in your Dopp kit
when you travel it's super nice it's
great and it does the job check it out
get quick comm slash Jen and Jillian
just $25 to start guys come on think
about it also guys me undies
my favorite [ __ ] people on the
Internet I love me Andes I love the
people behind me undies I love the
designs they create me Andes is three
times softer than cotton they have
perfected the formula of good looking
and good feeling underwear that come
shipped to your door you don't have to
go shopping in a mall for underwear who
wants to [ __ ] do that I don't want to
do that they work with amazing people
like them the me andis family extends so
far on the internet and it's really
wonderful
and like once you think you have your
favorite design with me Andes they come
out where the cooler design next month
they literally work with really really
awesome and like established artists to
create cool prints on their underwear
they have brought let's they have socks
they even have like pajama pants that I
love they've sponsored and supported us
for many many years and they are
wonderful guys check it out by going to
me on these that's meu NDI es dot-com
slash annejulien get 15% off your first
pair free shipping and if you don't like
it you get a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee which I don't
think you'll need to worry about it all
because you're gonna love it
check it out me and ease thank you
sponsors thank you sponsors what does
that say Julian does that actually say
don't even get me started
waiters who insist on taking your order
by memory and then messing it up what
are you trying to prove what are you
trying to prove okay I get it you want
to come off as the slick waiter who
knows the menu really well who wants to
be personable and have a fun
conversation I don't need no no pad dude
I got this right here okay I trust this
notepad points the head take take your
order oh we have a table full of 12
people all have really specific orders
and some have dietary restrictions no
problem I'm just gonna butcher it all
back in the kitchen and then bring you
some other [ __ ] and then ruin everyone's
night now listen I'm not in any way
shape or form
coming down on waiters who want to be
good entertainers or personable because
I've seen it done right but it takes a
long time to get to that point of being
able to be the waiter who's like
what do you guys want mmm okay got it
mm-hmm okay mute okay hmm it repeats it
back in perfect unison and then bounces
comes back with all the food I've seen
that and I know how magical it is but if
you haven't gotten there yet
don't just fake it till you make it
because it's gonna make all of us suffer
and when we're all hungry and we get the
wrong food I'm not gonna be happy and
I'm not gonna really care about your
charm anymore because I'm not getting
the calories that this needs to run this
this train also how hard would it have
been to maybe just like take a couple
notes you don't need to write every
single order down but hey if the guy
with the curly hair is getting a weird
salad like a Pittsburgh salad just write
that down just like a little note to
help you okay curly hair
Pittsburgh salad fine done that way you
don't mess that up but the rest of it
you got don't come don't come at me with
this memory
Shaam of you pretending to know what we
want and then throwing it back in our
face with the wrong food I don't
appreciate it I'm hungry any time you're
dealing with someone who's hungry you
have to you're pleasing them at all
costs right okay it's the same when when
when you order food and it takes three
hours to get there like I could have
done a 3-hour meal at home but that's my
city I'm good at that I came to you
because you're quicker than that can you
make it faster and I could have had I
could have had my wife ignore what I
wanted to eat at home not you okay I
need you to listen to me that's why I
came to your establishment sir please
ignore me
don't even get me started on how much my
wife ignores me write it down can I do
stories yeah so when I drove across the
country
I stopped in Montana and was there with
some friends and we were there for a
couple days we went to this is in the
middle of Montana like fishtail like
very small so we like drove 20 minutes
half an hour to a restaurant and it was
like the only one around
and they served like very specific and
different types of like elk and moose
and I was eating me at that point and um
you know we're at a table with like 8 9
10 people I don't know a bunch of people
and there's all these modifications
everything's super specific and our
waiter is like really friendly really
nice but we're going around the table
and every like everything that you're
ordering has like you know a sauce a rub
aside you know a different side a drink
and he's doing them all at once and so
each person like as you're saying what
you'd like to eat is taking you know a
couple minutes each we're going around
table we're doing this and he's just
standing there going uh-huh okay got it
and we're all just like a little like is
he gonna eventually pull out a piece of
paper to write something down like it's
a teeny tiny restaurant and like there's
only groups of like two everywhere else
around us and I'm just like okay and I'm
I'm like I know you're ranting to rant
but like also like I respect these
people for sure that work in the service
industry
I also if you're if you're the type of
waiter to do that I'm not gonna doubt
your expertise I think maybe something
might go wrong but like also I admire
you in you hustle right now totally
we're going all around and I'm just
silently like a little bit amazed
because I would have checked out 20
minutes into this [ __ ] or I would
have been like he yes sure totally
served whatever the [ __ ] I felt like he
walks away after everyone gives their
order and all the guys at the table
start laughing cuz they're like I'm just
gonna I'm probably gonna get like a
ketchup popsicle like there's an
absolutely no [ __ ] way that he
remembered and they're all like laughing
and joking like not to be mean or
anything but just like there's just no
way yeah so because it's such a small
restaurant this boy and he's like I
don't know in his early 20s like
beautiful young man like lovely lively
amazed like like the the perfect waiter
like can't wait to serve you and have a
good time he comes back over and he was
like I forget how he said it but it was
so politely backhanded it was just like
oh okay I just wanted to
sure that I got everyone's order correct
and he without blinking at anybody
literally looked at every person was
like you're gonna have the the deer elk
with the werster sir like sauce and then
and then pizza perfectly verbatim back
to everyone to the face
it was the most epic [ __ ] clap back I
have ever seen and all the boys like
their their jaws dropped like it was
amazing it was the best thing [ __ ]
ever in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and he collect back at the whole table
and it was wild it was wild
for every bad experience I think was
somebody like doing that and then
[ __ ] something up which means naughty
there's one mind-blowing oh my it was
amazing
it was the most like what I mean that's
like that's what the people who who
aren't good at it yet but want to try it
that's their goal they want to be that
guy it was so safe yeah it was so
[ __ ] sick it's pretty cool when
people can do that because it's like
clearly a really really honed skill
slash gift yes that you've kind of
figured out yeah and it makes such a
difference but yeah that's that's good
story it was amazing all right get
started don't even get me started see
the words oh don't even get me started
my paper receipt still exists oh man you
were just like go somewhere like I I
worked in retail I worked at a tanning
salon I worked at a bar like I worked in
places where you quote keep receipts
right and you have somebody sign it not
just like I got receipts but like
literal receipts they all get thrown out
like what the hell
why are you Lee signing millions of tiny
little pieces of paper I got one counter
why one counter argument what bartenders
we always kept a cup of receipts just
because if the if we were entering like
a bill into the POS and we couldn't read
the handwriting or maybe the bill was
lost or something we always had a backup
receipt in the cup so I think that was
like the only reason why anyone should
have a
a receipt a paper receipt why can't we
do this all electronically at this point
I don't know some bars aren't there yet
it's not just bars it's literally
everywhere what about CVS
yeah it's literally everywhere why can't
we do this all electronically a CVS is
killing trees like so rapidly yes they
are single-handedly killing all the
world's trees it's irresponsible I agree
what about what about when people are
like here's your change can they give
you the receipt and then they just drop
all the chains on top of it so you're
just like now I hate everything in my
hand I literally like don't use cash for
anything I haven't had that happen to me
in like seven years oh you know I use
cash I don't like to be traced I don't I
don't use cash okay but even like why
why do we have paper receipts why can't
we do this all electronically you know
what my favorite thing is when I'm
advanced and cerebral and millennial
enough to use Apple pay I'll still get
handed a paper receipt that's what I'm
saying why I don't know man
I don't know you basically just took
this this new system we've developed and
you've thrown in on its ass you do dude
on it dude it honor with the receipt I
literally just sent the tree here people
why do I need a paper receipt if I have
an electronic receipt I don't know man
it's so dumb just in case the world ends
and you want to like make sure that your
boss gives you the money that he owes
you for going to get him a [ __ ] salad
I wish I could tell you the last time I
actually kept a receipt and then use it
to return something 99% of times that I
returned something it's either an Amazon
return where I'm like okay I'll ship it
back you have all you have all the data
in your system or it's like Guitar
Center where I have like an account with
them and I need to exchange it or
something they're like okay look up your
account oh it's here BAM I'm not gonna
keep a [ __ ] piece of paper ever
stupid I just don't know why it so
exists I'm sure there's plenty of
logical reasons but for me personally I
feel like it's a little silly let me
know in the comment comments your turn
your turn boy hello yeah
I have a stone don't even I don't wanna
okay
no one's not that good don't even get me
started on people who just go ahead and
pet dogs or gate without asking or
gauging the dog's interest I can't even
tell you how many times at the dark park
and there are people mind you these
aren't just these aren't just bystanders
these aren't just regular civilians
these are [ __ ] people who are a dog
people with a group of dogs and they are
paid to watch dogs that don't know how
to be around other people's dogs they
don't know etiquette with animals they
just there's this one [ __ ] lady doing
it and I'm telling you like marbles must
think this woman is the Wicked Witch of
the West because of the way she comes at
marbles regularly like not once like a
bunch of times she sticks her hands out
like the Grinch like and then walks
towards him reaching downward while
making these high-pitched noises about
how cute he is and he's losing his [ __ ]
I'm scared
he's barking he's backing up he's
digging his feet in his hair is standing
there standing up he's barking barking
oh dude you're literally paid to be good
with dogs and you're doing that like
I've seen children who have better dog
manners because they were taught how to
act with dogs like I don't understand
how people there any adults animals
really yes but dogs is the main focus I
don't get how adults don't teach their
kids not like not to do that to dogs or
animals you like you gauge the the
animals interest you may be sitting next
to them you let them sniff you you know
there's ways to do it that are like
comfortable for everybody I don't get
help like parents aren't able to teach
their kids that because there are kids
that just run it animals like crazy and
that always causes for a bad situation
but not only that adults themselves
don't know how to interact with pets
well they're just oh he boogy boogy like
dude what are you kidding me that's not
a [ __ ] toy like regardless of whether
or not that dog is gonna like bite or
snap back that's the dog hates it do you
care don't even [ __ ] get me started
dude what if a [ __ ] Bigfoot 40-foot
giant came up to you and just started
touching your head really [ __ ]
violently the [ __ ] you would like you
would run away terrified for your
[ __ ] life that's what these dogs are
do
hello get a clue what well you you also
see like occasionally in the news you
see people that are like doing things to
animals that are just like mind-blowing
it's like why are you doing that like Oh
a man gets [ __ ] you know run over by
a ball or something cuz he's just out
there poking it and teasing it and
[ __ ] touching it you deserve to do
you know listen people who go into those
like safari parks and get out of the
earth know so I've been in those like
where you can drive your own car through
the safari or whatever and there's a lot
of rules like don't feed the animals
period don't open your window
don't try and give them food because
they like it they want your food they
then they're gonna try to get more of it
yeah and so like no matter what the sign
say no matter what all the things that
you like you actually sign a piece of
paper that's like I'm not gonna be a
dick you see the cars in front of you
people like rolling their windows down
giving french fries like all those
videos online of people with like a
giraffe sticking their head through the
window that's because people have
conditioned them they break the rules
they go in there they don't care because
they think it's [ __ ] funny
it's so [ __ ] we're the [ __ ] worst
man people are the worst things to
happen to animals but then but then so
the animals like lions and all that [ __ ]
like it's great there's a bunch of them
in Canada too or you can gently drive
through there and they have like actual
lions they're like don't [ __ ] around
they roll down a window they feed them
and then the animal gets pissed off if
you you know roll up your window and
take the food away from them so they
start destroying your car like they rip
off your antenna there's people dying
like that like you're a woman got like
ripped away by a lion tariff well she
actually didn't die I think she just got
really [ __ ] up but still like but then
those people have the audacity to try
and like sue that place or be like you
need to pay my car got ruined it's like
you are feeding an animal what are you
doing but it's those types of people
that don't really have the wherewithal
to grasp that an animal is its own being
they're just like you came in for me and
so it's giving you so many clues about
how I don't want you to touch me or how
I want your food or like that kind of
stuff that people just refuse to
acknowledge it like breaks my heart
sometimes when marbles is like forced to
be the dick and like marbles yeah he's a
chihuahua he's naturally aggressive he's
protective all that sure he's not
aggressive hold on hold on he's he's you
know he's protective and he can he can
snap because he's a chihuahua and if you
like come at him whatever like it gives
people and other animals it breaks
boundaries it breaks my heart sometimes
to see like it's like when it's like
when people mistreat the [ __ ] out of
pitbulls and then the pitbulls nasty and
attacks things it's like well now you've
put this dog in this horrible position
and this is obviously a much smaller
extent when I'm talking about marbles
like you put this dog in a position to
where you're mistreating it and so it's
like giving you these signs that aren't
like pretty its barking right it's like
not a happy scene but you've created the
situation so where now you can just be
like oh that dogs aggressive
oh that dogs barking that's a nasty
little chihuahua no [ __ ]
you came at this dog the wrong way you
didn't learn basic animal etiquette
you're treating them like a like a toy
rather than an actual living being
because you want to think they're cute
and come at them with all sorts of weird
body language that your parents never
taught you we're wrong [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that I just don't get like when people
want to touch an animal regardless of
whether it's a pet whether you see it
outside like animals always give you
clear signals about whether or not
they'd like to be touched or that kind
of thing and if it's awesome if it's a
person's dog right and you can talk to
them and you can be like do you think
it'd be all right if I try and pet him
like maybe you're having a conversation
with them sure like I don't understand
who taught these people to never like
get down or like have the animal smell
you first you know if they have no
problem maybe don't just go in for the
head and like give them one of these
like an ice chest scratch like something
non-threatening it's like people just
never learn how to interact with their
little pets and we'll two hours they
don't have feelings they don't
understand they're just here to be pet
by me because if someone with any
wherewithal walks up to marbles and when
they start getting too close to him he
does he might growl his hair might stand
up he might start walking away or like
you know trying not to be in that
situation if the person's getting too
close
he might bark at them yeah and then it's
never a person that's like
when they see that they're like do you
think I could pet him because I'd be
like well probably not he's he's sort of
giving you all the signals like please
don't touch me you know like nothing
personal I just don't know you and
you're a giant and you're already coming
at me it's the people that see all of
that ignore it still try and touch him
don't say anything to me and aren't
interacting with him whatsoever they
just want to touch him like he doesn't
want to be touched she's telling you he
doesn't want to be touched
nothing personal fam just he doesn't
want to be touched neither do i when I'm
out in the world you know yeah it's so
[ __ ] depressing that people can't
grasp that dude imagine just a person
walking up to you and going like this
and then if you're like whoa man hey
maybe don't touch me and they're just
like self-defense my mind the same
language yeah don't touch me even if we
didn't speak the same language you spoke
French and I spoke English and you came
home - no it's a reversal like don't
touch me what yeah oh man do you wanna
do one more each don't even get me
started on how dr. Phil is allowed to be
that sexy oh where do I start with this
he's got a big go on he's got a big
chunk trunk full of a lot of junk oh
he's wearing that dashing suit every day
oh his feet are like size 20 Oh his head
is as shiny as the top of the Chrysler
Building Wow
that wasn't any reference oh okay right
I don't know it was he sits on that
highest [ __ ] chair looking down on me
dad
he's fixing people's lives for no
financial gain only because of the good
of his heart he wears rings the size of
my car on his dick sausage fingers his
moustache just will not quit and yeah I
just dream about it I don't know
you know I don't think he should be
allowed to be that sexy yes he married I
think about how married is yeah I don't
think that's I think that's fair to the
rest of us that don't have thick daddy
dr. Phil's to look at everything how was
that allowed how is that allowed
oh and I'm supposed to keep my hands to
myself Oh what he's looking so sexy oh
my god we just talked about this we
didn't account for the scenario where
you run into dr. Phil and you lose
control of your body oh I want a
different one we need a good one to end
I'm just thinking about that mustache
now hmm okay if you couldn't tell Jenna
wrote that card so some of these are why
we poop and pee into fresh water people
who demand to have week-long birthday
celebrations ye Bay still exists my room
service prices are so expensive all
really good to rant about but I think we
should rants about why being ticklish
serves for no survival advantage and
it's stupid okay ticklish stupid why are
we ticklish because if I deserve this I
could probably end this by just googling
it but I wanted to it's stupid
what if yeah I have nothing I don't know
what humans are doing why are we
ticklish animals ticklish I don't know
maybe it's a way of touching that's
intimate but not quite like intimate
intimate like sex stuff but like also
not threatening like danger so it's like
a middle ground like if you're getting
tackled hard yeah you're a tickle attack
that's scary
[Music]
he's so ticklish right under his head I
hate it I hate it it's but it's aside
for those the documentary who were
tickled for they like tickle you know
each other for money while I'm around
[ __ ] aside from that
there's no there's no purpose that it
serves those guys tickling fetish those
guys it was a career to us it's weird it
serves that serves nothing it's stupid
tickling it's stupid but like from an
evolutionary standpoint like why would
you develop being tickle my ticklish I
wish dude I could just raise my arms up
to the sky and everyone could just do
that underneath my arms and I wouldn't
feel anything and I would just be able
to all right let me just because I'm
lazy and I felt like just you know
complaining about it before I actually
figure it out let me just google it
really quick why are we ticklish I'm
interested in this I don't have any idea
why we be ticklish we can't take all
ourselves this is because your brain
takes your movement and intention into
account when responding to the sensation
and this reduces the ticklish thing we
know that no one can tickle themselves
you're crazy curious kids why are we
ticklish okay there are different kinds
of tickles
okay clickbait why don't you tell me why
the [ __ ] would tickle it
what scientists used to think about 150
years ago a famous scientist named
Charles Darwin thought tickling was
linked to our sense of humor he thought
this because we laugh when we tickle
when when tickled just as when we laugh
when we find something funny scientists
found this is wrong because when we find
something funny we laugh as a sign of
enjoyment but lots of people don't enjoy
being tickled which is why when they
laugh and smile they can't help it some
scientists think that it could be when
we cry from cutting onions okay like
that type that type of a response
doesn't mean that you're sad other
people have thought the tickling was a
way to build a relationship between
other people's brothers and sisters or a
parent with their child scientists have
found that this isn't right either which
is what and and we can be tickled by
robots while this is quite hard also
robots can [ __ ] tickle you [ __ ] oh
my god okay what we think could be the
cause we can't tickle ourselves this is
because your brain okay blah blah blah
your brain has to deal with a lot of
information coming in all the time when
that touches from
another person or thing this is
important to know it could be a spider
crawling on you okay this is why that's
not [ __ ] like having a tickle response
is invade that spider this hasn't given
me any information that I found helpful
okay this says right from the Los
Angeles Times why are we ticklish
scientists who tickled rats offer his
nipped reading answer say honey how was
your day sounds pretty good to grab
apparently can be tickled because
scientists did it because they tested on
rats right let's pour rats floor rats I
personally think it's like it's that
like inter intermediate stage between
like pleasure and like and like fighter
flight i gets tickling it's like
somewhere in the middle that maybe like
I think I don't know man
so to give you the gist of this it says
tickling might be a trick of the brain
to make animals or humans respectively
interact and play with each other I
still don't think make sense like from
from an evolutionary standpoint we were
gonna really find even like one clear
answer we were given the ability to be
ticklish to encourage us to play with
each other dude if someone knows me I
don't want to be with them I don't want
to be their friend I don't want to be
around them I don't trust them anymore I
think I think when their hands are free
I don't like it in fact I've seen tickle
fights go so south to where this is
violence there's times when we've been
tickling each other and like Julian is
such a violent response to getting
tickle where you've like almost kicked
me in the head like yeah like really
jerks around like how did we develop the
ability to be ticklish and tickle is
that gonna make anybody closer with it
that's one thing I'm curious to see what
what you guys are gonna best us in the
comments no more tickling
have you ever been tickled so bad that
you peed tickle in pee no but I've
tickle I've been tickled so bad that I
sweat and become uncomfortable and it's
intimate and I don't like it and yeah
like my body jerks around in weird
[ __ ] movements I don't like that the
person tickling me doesn't like that but
they signed up for it
all that's bad this whole scenario is
giving I'm sweating you're sweating I'm
sorry I just think that what if instead
of laughing tickling just made you like
like sweat like it's profusely look out
of all your glands
on that note I'm gonna have a tickle
fight no cuz I'll get like kicked in the
head you'll break my nose okay you know
that's extreme is it yes it's extreme to
say I'll break your nose thank you we're
gonna in the podcast before you make me
pee or sweat well this concludes well if
you don't like being tickled well if you
tickling getting tickled sucks but at
least you'll be tickled while you're
wearing me undies thank you guys for
watching please let us know in the
comments how wrong we were on all these
things and look you guys next week for
another podcast don't tickle each other
it doesn't breed friendship it breeds
enemy ship yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]